[Music]  margot robbie transforms into Queen  Elizabeth the first and leaves us asking  who's that hi boys check out this photo  of Margot in London on the set of Mary  Queen of Scots the 27 year old Aussie  actress treated in her long blond locks  and youthful beauty to get into  character  sporting a curly red - pasty white  makeup and a blotchy complexion Margot  is nearly unrecognizable and those  clothes the actress was decked out in  traditional Tudor wear complete with a  corset and wide buckled skirt it's what  we do  Margot will star opposite Brooklyn  actress Saoirse Ronan who plays Mary  Queen of Scots we have a life halfway  across the sea also starring in the film  Taylor Swift's new beau Joe Allen Allen  is set to take on the role of Dudley  Queen Elizabeth's counselor and lover  the movie is expected to hit theaters in  2018  [Music]  you